this video was made possible by
curiosity stream when you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash went over
you'll also get access to nebula the
streaming video platform that Wendover
is a part of there's a battle going on
in the Pacific the People's Republic of
China and the Republic of China more
commonly known as Taiwan have fought
their territorial dispute for
generations but now nearly each and
every one of the tiny nations dotting
the Pacific Ocean has emerged as a
battlefield for this conflict the
weapons of this war are not guns and
bullets but rather concrete and
banknotes this is a diplomatic mission
aiming to shore up the support of some
of the world's smallest
countries there are 14 nations in
question here Palau Papua New Guinea the
Federated States of Micronesia the
Solomon Islands Nauru Vanuatu the
Marshall Islands Fiji Tuvalu Tonga
Cerebus Samoa Nui
and the Cook Islands with the exception
of Papua New Guinea
each of these have populations below 1
million and each also tends to have
fairly low GDP per capita
generally between one and five thousand
dollars this means that they're each
granted fairly significant amounts of
foreign aid in the previous decade Nui
for example received 134 million dollars
in aid or about 83,000 dollars for each
member of its population region-wide
that average is only in the low
thousands but the point is that the
Pacific gets a lot of eight now most of
this does not come from Taiwan or China
Australia is by far the largest donor it
is important for Australia to be in
these countries good graces for
strategic reasons for example six
percent of Australia's GDP is made up
solely of exports that take one of these
three maritime routes each of which
passes by some of these Pacific
countries these trade routes could be
disrupted if there were instability in
the pacific political stability also
keeps foreign powers from attempting a
power grab in any one of these nations
and any such power grab would likely be
too close for comfort for Australia so
the primary aid motivation for Australia
and its close allies like New Zealand
and the US
is stability that is not the primary
motivation for China and Taiwan these
two powers are openly engaging in what's
known as checkbook diplomacy they're
buying diplomatic partners through
financial aid but why China is a massive
nation of more than a billion people
what benefit does it receive from having
tiny nations like Samoa Tonga or Fiji on
its side well they might gain some
limited benefit but the main reason
China works to build these diplomatic
partnerships is so Taiwan cannot that's
because to Taiwan even a tiny 11,000
person nation like Tuvalu is hugely
valuable as Tuvalu has something Taiwan
doesn't Tuvalu is a member of the United
Nations Taiwan is rarely recognized as
an independent country in international
settings this is despite the fact that
in almost every way it acts and operates
as an independent country would there
are plenty of countries like the US for
example that have strong relations with
Taiwan and treat it as if it were a
country the US has a de facto embassy in
Taiwan recognises Taiwanese passports
sales military supplies to Taiwan and
has an enormous ly strong trade
relationship with Taiwan yet it does not
recognize Taiwan as a country that's
because in international relations there
is an implicit rule you either recognize
the Republic of China or the People's
Republic of China now given the choice
between working with the world to his
populist country or a moderately sized
island of 24 million nearly every nation
picks China even though Taiwan and the
u.s. are functionally allies while China
in the US are frenemies at best it's
just not worth while for the u.s. to
recognise Taiwan as a country this is
the case for almost every country that
is of course unless Taiwan makes it
worthwhile
across the Pacific Taiwan has been
funding projects to keep small nations
on its side in Palau
they spent 1.3 million dollars to help
the country recover from typhoon Haiyan
in Papua New Guinea they spent 4.5
million dollars to improve domestic
agriculture in order to increase food
security in the Solomon Islands
they spent 2.5 million dollars to train
local staff and conduct a survey of the
islands local plant species in Nauru
they spent $600,000 donating more
efficient compact fluorescent light
bulbs to local households in the
Marshall Islands they spent 1 million
dollars building a seawall around Majuro
atoll to protect it from rising sea
levels in Fiji
they spent $300,000 improving mental
health service access around the country
in Tuvalu they spent $200,000 repairing
and improving water storage equipment
around the country after a cyclone in
kiri Baz they spent 19 million dollars
to repair and upgrade the country's main
airport each of these projects in the
hundreds more funded by Taiwan around
the Pacific improves its relations with
these countries and therefore brings it
more and more diplomatic clout Taiwan
can't afford to buy the support of large
nations but in some settings the size of
the nation doesn't matter in the United
Nations General Assembly for example
it's one country one vote it doesn't
matter if it's Tuvalu or China when
voting every member nation has the exact
same power there are other systems in
the UN where power is more balanced
based on population but overall the
world's smallest nations have a
disproportionate amount of power more
recognition even by the smallest
countries strengthens Taiwan's case for
a position in intergovernmental
organizations like the UN that's why
Taiwan targets small nations for support
5 million dollar spent on Tuvalu goes a
lot further than 5 million dollar spent
on Mexico for example but in the General
Assembly
Tuvalu can help Taiwan just as much as
Mexico can this diplomatic clout that
Taiwan has amassed though gets in the
way of China's ambition of eventually
unifying the two it is for that reason
that the People's Republic has gone on
the offensive China has been courting
Taiwan's diplomatic partners in the
Pacific
with promises of larger aid packages the
most recent two defectors were kiri boss
and the Solomon Islands early in the
2010s China provided no foreign aid to
either of these countries but then as
soon as they each revoked their
recognition of Taiwan promises of planes
ferries medical supplies and more
started pouring in from China in
addition to these two countries Taiwan
has lost diplomatic support from the
Dominican Republic Burkina Faso
El Salvador Panama and South oh man
Principi in 2016 that leaves them with
just 15 total diplomatic partners and
only four in the Pacific region to
maintain the limited support that it has
Taiwan has had to get tactical China's
style with aid is to build big flashy
expensive infrastructure projects in
Fiji they spent 50 million dollars
building a paved road that halved the
time it took for local farmers to get to
markets but local engineers reportedly
said that a far lower quality and
cheaper Road could have achieved the
same result in Vanuatu they spent eighty
million dollars upgrading a port to
allow for larger cruise ships to dock
but in all of 2019 for example just five
visited in Papua New Guinea they spent 1
million dollars building a malaria
hospital in the capital of Port Moresby
despite that being the region of the
country with the least malaria and
despite the capital having no road link
to the region's with the worst malaria
outbreaks each of these projects and
more clearly have positive effects but
undoubtedly they are not the most
efficient uses of one or 50 or 80
million dollars in the mission of
improving relations between China and
the specific nations China does big
flashy and sometimes ineffective aid
taiwan does small personable and
generally more effective aid that's why
they have been able to maintain the
relationships they have for so long
despite a much lower budget china works
to impress the government's taiwan works
to impress the people taiwan's average
aid project size in the pacific is
$500,000 China's is
six million dollars taiwan does things
like contribute sixteen hundred dollars
for Palau baseball team to attend a
tournament in Guam or spend two hundred
thousand dollars buying a boat for an
outer ad toll in the Marshall Islands or
construct $300,000 of solar streetlights
in not room the 80 million dollar port
in Vanuatu might help people more than
the $1,600 for the baseball team in
Palau but one can be sure that every
member of that team and their families
and friends heard about and remember how
Taiwan helped them that's less likely
with the large somewhat ineffective port
taiwan knows that the choice of which
side to support is a political issue in
the pacific because there is that choice
pretty much any politician in these
countries will run their campaign with
the Taiwan issue as part of their
platform and so Taiwan is trying to gain
the support of everyday people they want
to win support from the ground up rather
and from the top down this might create
a better value for their money but at
the end of the day China just has so
much more money if China wants to win
the political support of a small nation
they can just spend and spend and spend
at this point Taiwan's few tiny
diplomatic partners are no longer a
threat to China's goal of reunification
China will likely keep courting these
nations not because they need to but
because it'll further weaken Taiwan
eventually though if there comes a day
when the Taiwan issue is resolved either
through reunification or recognized
independence the Pacific Islands will be
victims because when they're no longer
useful the pawn is the first to be
sacrificed if you want to learn more
about one of the four Pacific island
nations that are still on Taiwan side
the Marshall Islands
you can watch the nebula exclusive
documentary we filmed on location in the
Marshall Islands you heard earlier that
Taiwan funded a sea wall for the Capitol
mash row but the final years of mash row
explains why that was necessary and what
it means for the nation it explains what
life is like in a nation with a neck
operation date the best way to get
access to that is to sign up for
curiosity streams nebula bundled you'll
curiosity stream is of course home to
thousands of documentaries that any went
over viewer will enjoy and nebula is
home to all of wind overs normal videos
early and at free plus special exclusive
projects like this documentary what's
more it's not only when over on there
but half is interesting real engineering
brain craft tears ooh real-life floor
and more and more of your favorite
educational creators so once again sign
up for any subscription at true Aussie
stream comm slash Wendover for as little
as twenty dollars a year and get access
to nebula for free